- I could either save
money or I could just--
- Wow, those look good.
- Should we get some?
- I don't know. They're pretty gay.
- We're gay.
- Alright, fine.
Excuse me, sir, two of
those fruity drinks, please.
- Good call.
- Yeah, these are amazing.
How does this look?
- It looks good, that's why I bought it.
- Yeah?
- Mhm.
As long as you don't do that.
(mumbling)
- [Waiter] How would you like to--
- [Both] We'll split it.
Are you scrolling through
some random guy's Instagram right now?
- Yeah, but look how hot he is.
- Oh my God. He is hot.
Wait, click on the shirtless one.
Wait, what's his handle?
Wait, did you wash your hands?
- No.
- Come on!
- Can I be the little spoon?
- Just one more minute.
- It's my turn.
- Fine.
(belching)
- Nice.
- Yes, queen!
- Mhm.
- Get swole, bro.
- Don't stop, don't stop.
- Get swole!
Can you believe marriage equality
only passed two years ago?
- I know.
It really makes you think, huh?
- I love you.
- I love you, too.
(jazz music)